the reasoning for why Biden's building a
50 Cent Army is fairly obvious I do not
see them being able to pull off another
Victory I'm seeing all these polls where
they're like Biden is beating Trump in
these states Biden is beating Trump and
I'm like don't care don't believe it I
mean look ballot harvesting may come to
save the day but it's clear that they're
going to be ramping up what I would
describe as unethical and malicious
tactics in the election and the idea of
of a Democrat so for those who don't
know the 50 Cent Army what is it in
China anybody who Pro posts on social
media Pro CCP propaganda they get paid
50 cents every time they do or something
like that
so this is basically what we're gonna
start seeing with Democrats and that's
probably what's already happening so
we're talking about anheuser-boy if
we're talking about Dylan Mulvaney and
the algorithmic manipulation
that is what the Democrats are riding
that wave
yeah the the thing you didn't say which
I think needs to be said which speaks to
your point is what this does to the
Integrity of the system overall this is
what causes a legitimacy crisis right